LIGHTNING, MEETING FOR THE
>> I E E
O'CONNOR PLAYING
THAT.
YOU GO THROUGH A LIST OF ALL THE
GREAT GOALTENDERS IN THE HISTORY
OF THE GAME THEY HAHA LANGUAGE
PENS HISTORIAN BOBNO TRIES THE .
STICK OFF
MARINO.
>> Steve: MATHESON, HEINEN.
BATTLE ALONG
CHANCE, RODRÍGUEZ,
THAT.
WOW.
SUPEPE
ALONE.
ND
PETTERSSON WITH THAT LONG REACHE
CHIP PASS TO POINTS.
DUMOULIN TAKES AWAY THE PUCK.
RODRÍGUEZ TO DUMOULIN.
ELITE.
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES
SCORES.
ONDREJ PALAT ON THE HELP.WHERE.
>> Steve: STAMKOS McDONOUGHIS NT
FOR THE
KOLTEN, SHOVELED DOWN THE
BOARDS, BY WELL.
PETTERSSON, OVER TO
AGAIN.
PUTTING
GLOVE.
>> Steve: HEINEN WITH THE PUCKH.
ENTERTAINING HOCKE GLOVE
OF JAR SEE.
CERNAK HEAVY COLLISION WITH
IN THE
MATHESON.
OUT THERE.
ALONG WITH GUENTZEL. DOWN
THE EMPTYKED BY ZUCKER,
GUENTZEL REBOUND,
THE BLUE LINE AND THEN FOLLOWIN.
NET EMPTY.
NETTER.
>> Bob: IF YOU PULL THEM TO
SCORE ON THE POWER